bonsoir et bienvenue pour le journal de
la rédaction de TVfil 78 nouvelle
édition donc et dans l'actualité de ce
mercredi 11 février 2015 trouver un
professeur remplaçant dans une école se
révèle toujours un exercice périlleux il
est encore plus à trppe visiblement
l'association des parents d'élèves
indépendants dans la commune vient de se
mobiliser aujourd'hui nous en parlerons
tout à l'heure avec son président sur le
plateau le mouvement de Nicolas
dupontaignon sera bien présent dans les
ivelines pour les élections
départementales de mars de 8 des 21
cantons les électeurs pourront choisir
des candidats de bout la France et le 8
mars au plus tard il faudra équiper son
logement d'un détecteur de fumée une
obligation qui pose bien des problèmes à
certains particuliers ainsi la
préfecture lance une campagne pour bien
les conseiller avec l'aide vous l'avez
vu des pompiers des ivlines 6 milliards
d'Ur c'est le montant du budget initial
pour organiser les Jeux olympiques de
2024 dans la capitale un coup
relativement faible qui pourrait bien
séduire la merire de Paris anidalgo Le
Parisien s'en faisait l'écho ce matin
nos confrères viennent de dévoiler le
rapport du Comité français du sport
international qui sera présenté remis
dans quelques heures aux élus justement
on y apprend que le vélodrome de 50 ans
en Yveline pourrait faire partie des
sites retenu le site a été inauguré
l'année dernière d'ailleurs et il devait
servir au Joo de 2012 mais Londres avait
emporté souvenez-vous cela marquerait
une belle revanche le vélodrome qui va
d'ailleurs servir d'écrain au mondiaux
du cyclisme sur piste dans quelques
jours enfin selon un sondage publié par
Direct Matin 73 % des Français et 76 %
des Franciliens sont favorables à
l'organisation de nouveaux jeux
olympiques dans notre pays les élections
départementales on en parle une fois de
plus ce soir avec cette annonce du Parti
communiste dans le canton de trappe et
en cours la verrière il n'y aura pas de
soutien à la candidature du maire de La
Verrière à lainjage pourtant membre du
PCF et qui a choisi de se rapprocher de
la sortante divivers gauche sur le
secteur Jeanine Marie élu elle aussi
attrape mieux ou pire c'est selon il y
aura même une liste d'alliance avec les
gécologistes pour les pour le parti
communiste le Front de Gauche nous
sommes en ligne avec Luc miseret bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes membre du Parti
communiste élu à trappe et surtout
candidat pour ces départementales tout
d'abord pourquoi il n'y a pas d'union
derrière la candidature du maire de La
Verrière pourtant communiste bah parce
que c'est une initiative individuelle du
maire de La Verrière au parti
communiste il y a la démocratie il y a
eu un vote la majorité des communistes
se sont prononcé pour avoir une liste de
rassemblement à gauche mais proposant
une alternative au logique
gouvernementale actuelle à la fois parce
qu'on les partage pas et ensuite parce
que pour mobiliser les gens qui sont
déçus et désespérés de la situation
actuelle et bien il faut offrir et
ouvrir une alternative à gauche et c'est
ce qu'on fait avec le rassemblement qui
est scellé entre les ver le mouvement
citoyen le Parti communiste le Front de
gauche le Parti de Gauche et bien
d'autres donc vous serez vous serez
candidat on va y venir mais le maire de
La Verrière ça veut dire que vous
souhaitez qu'il soit exclu en tout cas
mis en retrait du du Parti communiste
actuellement quelles sont les les
relations avec
lui le maire de La Verrière il prend une
individuelle donc moi je n'ai pas à me
prononcer là-dessus moi je souhaite pas
spécialement qu'il soit exclus
simplement je souhaite qu'il ne se
revendique pas de du Parti communiste
parce qu'aujourd'hui la le seul accord
qui existe passé par Parti communiste au
niveau local et dans nombre d'autres
cantons hein puisque le canton à côté de
MPa maniéam Chevreuse le canton de de
saint-ir le canton de euh oui il
effectivement de nombreux contons qui
ont décidé de faire l'alliance entre les
forces du
front il y a des tas d'endroits où il y
a des des liens euh avec les verrs mais
sur le secteur de de trape sur votre
secteur sur sur votre secteur vous
n'avez pas peur malgré tout que les
électeurs s'y perdent un petit peu les
électeurs de laavrière par exemple s'ils
veulent voter pour leur maère pour une
liste communiste qui ressemble à une
liste d'union de la gauche he Jeanine
Marie étant élu divers gauche mais ça se
fait avec l'alliance du du Parti
socialiste vous n'avez pas peur que les
électeurs se se perdent et que ça
favorise finalement aussi la candid de
la droite qui sera porté notamment par
le maire d'élancours Jean-Michel
Fourgous pour l'UMP mais ça ce n'est pas
notre responsabilité c'est de la
responsabilité d'alin Haage donc il a
fait ce choix il est respectable mais
c'est de sa responsabilité à lui et
c'est de la responsabilité de Jeanine
Marie qui soit dit en passant vote plus
souvent avec la droite au Conseil
Général qu'avec le groupe de gauche dont
elle a été exclu par notamment les
conseillers généraux socialistes donc
c'est une très grande confusion
effectivement que cette
composition hétéroclite dans laquelle
nous on se reconnaît pas et donc pour
mettre de la clarté dans le débat
politique et ben effectivement on
propose une véritable alternative de
gauche alors quels sont les points
justement qui vous rassemble avec votre
binôme puisque maintenant ce sont des
binômes qui se présentent pour Europe
Écologie Les vert ce sera Esther la fite
quels sont les points de rassemblement
autour du du programme que vous allez
défendre et bien notamment que justement
ce conseil général qui est dans un
département qui est riche mais où il y a
beaucoup d'inégalités territoriale et
d'inégalité sociale de travailler et
d'evrer à ce que elle soit plus reconnu
qu'il fa plus pour le social plus pour
l'environnement plus pour la petite
enfance la jeunesse les personnes âgées
le
handicap et ça c'est possible les
ressources existent ils se elles sont
limitées par des choix de ce de cette
direction du conseil général mais il y a
la possibilité de faire autre chose donc
c'est ce que nous on portera et qu'on
fondra parce que nos populations en ont
bien besoin merci Luc miser candidat
donc pour ces élections départementales
sur un binôme avec ester la fit une
alliance Europe Écologie les vers Front
de gauche comme on la retrouve
d'ailleurs dans de nombreux cantons sur
ce département nous en parlerons plus en
détail demain avec Julien ébor il est le
responsable départemental du Parti
communiste français le parti de Nicolas
dupontaignan sera présent à l'occasion
des départementales lui aussi dans les
ivelines les candidats seront présents
dans 8 des 21 canton sur notre secteur
plus particulièrement sur saint-ir
l'école et sur plaisir le point
Catherine zulato et lodim
moine debout la France anciennement
Debout la République présente des
candidats dans huit cantons Fabien met
pâtissier aujourd'hui étudiant en
histoire et Plaisirois depuis toujours
également conseiller municipal élu sur
la liste de la merre Joséphine
colmberger il se présente pour défendre
trois thèmes l'éthique politique une
bonne gestion financière de du
département et le bon sens afin de
servir au mieux le le bien-être des élus
noirs qui m'a donné envie de rejoindre
Debout la République enfin maintenant
debout la France c'est parce que j'ai
enfin je j'avais le sentiment que le
pays était mal géré depuis une
quarantaine d'années et que les partis
de gouvernement n'avaient pas réussi à
apporter des solutions adaptées à la
situation et je pense pas non plus que
la la la situation viendra des extrêmes
il fera campagne avec Pascal Michard
gérante de société à Plaisir autre binô
cette fois sur le canton de saint-sire
l'école Sylvia cantaloupi qui est de
toutes les campagnes politiques et
Christophe élu conseiller municipal
majoritaire à Villepreux ni système ni
extrême leur slogan de campagne on d
nettoyer la politique on essaie d'avoir
des élus propres nouveaux et qui
traînent pas des casseroles derrière eux
parce que après on est prisonnier
soi-même de ses habitudes et que au
conseil général il y a des bah c'est
c'est le train train quoi ils sont entre
eux ils font toujours les mêmes choses
les mêmes subventions les mêmes
comportements avoir des des subventions
qui soient vraiment utilisées pour pour
les les associations et les intérêts des
du canton de sain- déjà pour un premier
pour un premier point et surtout
utiliser et pouvoir
développer le département comme il
devrait l'être en dehors du FN qui
aujourd'hui est la seule alternative qui
est proposée par le système contre l'UMP
PS il y a une autre solution qui est
debout la France et moi j'essaie de
mener ce ce terrain là ces candidats
mèneront la campagne avec comme ils
disent les moyens du bord ils ne
disposent pas des finances des grands
partis ils feront donc beaucoup de
tractage pour faire connaître le parti
de Nicolas du
trop de professeurs absents non
remplacés dans les écoles de trapppe
c'est le message qu'on souhaitait faire
passer ce mercredi matin des parents
d'élèves de La Pet une app de trappe en
se rassemblant devant la mairie un
problème bien connu vous allez le voir
des service de l'inspection académique
qui s'exprime aussi sur ce
sujet une dizaine de parents trapiste
mobilisé ce mercredi matin pour demander
plus de professeurs remplaçant dans les
écoles de la commune on n pas de
remplaçant quand t professeurs sont
absents on manque de remplaçant de
manière c'est répétitive donc il y a un
ralbol parmi les parents dans l'école de
mes enfants oui il y a ce problème là
qui est récurrent on a une classe
notamment qui a pas eu d'enseignant
pendant 4 5 semaines et ça a des
incidences de toute manière sur toutes
les classes puisque du coup il y a les
enfants qui n'ont pas d'enseignant qui
sont réparti dans les classes qui se
retrouvent surchargé on est à 40 élèves
parfois quand il y a des enseignants
absents une pétition a été signée pour
revoir notamment le mode d'attribution
des professeurs remplaçants les parents
d'élèves ont été reçus en mairie pour
une première réunion ses parents qui
sont venus chercher le soutien de la
municipalité nous on a fait les
démarches auprès de de l'inspection
académique he c'est Jean Marie qui a
fait ça dans le cadre de son mandat et
et eux ils ont exprimé un besoin oui il
y a trop d'absence il y a vraiment
vraiment trop d'absence sur la ville de
trappe he c'est on peut pas être en
secteur d'éducation prioritaire on ne
peut pas dire que il faut que les
services publics se réinvestissent dans
dans des dans des secteurs urbains
fragiles et cetera puis en même temps
avoir une vingtaine d'instituteur
absent depuis longtemps une nouvelle
réunion est prévue le 20 mars avec les
services académiques une situation bien
connue le nouveau directeur éinois
réagissait d'ailleurs ce mardi soir sur
notre plateau actuellement on a
effectivement une une difficulté
objective nous avons remobiliser des
enseignants pour le premier degré de
manière à assurer les remplacements qui
sont dus quitte à prendre il faut bien
le dire avec regret hein sur notre
capacité de de remplacement des
professeurs qui partent en formation
les services académiques sont en train
d'identifier les circonscriptions qui
présentent le plus de difficultés en la
matière afin d'opérer dans le cadre de
la préparation de la rentrée prochaine à
rééquilibrage sur le manque de
professeurs
remplaçant et nous continuons à aborder
ce sujet en plateau à présent avec
Nicolas hardardi bonsoir vous êtes le
président dans les ivelines de l'Union
nationale des associations autonomes des
parents d'élèves on vient d'entendre le
directeur académique dans ce reportage
il était ti à votre place il semble
conscient de ce problème essayer d'y
apporter une réponse c'est ce qu'il t de
faire en tout cas est-ce que ça vous
satisfait aujourd'hui alors je d'abord
je salue le geste qui a été fait
puisqueeffectivement depuis plus d'une
semaine nous avons reçu cinq remplaçants
supplémentaires pour la circonscription
de trappe dont deux resteront jusqu'aux
vacan d'été alors effectivement 5 bon au
mois de janvier on était sur une
quinzaine d'absence non remplacé par
jour bon effectivement le compti est pas
là les beaux jours vont revenir donc ça
devrait s'atténuer et effectivement on
devrait je pense jusqu'au mois de juin à
être dans une enfin dans un dans un plan
un temps un peu un peu plus serein donc
déjà il y a ça va dans dans le bon sens
c'est c'est remplaçant ces remplaçants
qui sont trouvés hein par par l'Académie
mais juste pour revenir sur la situation
actuelle qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui
explique les absences des enseignants
spécifiquement sur trap pourquoi c'est
plus difficile aujourd'hui de trouver
des des enseignant al sur trap c'est
quand même c'est pas ça date pas
d'aujourd'hui hein ça fait des je crois
que je dà plusieurs fois venu surto pour
en parler alors les villes dites ZEP
comme Trapp on va dire Les Mureaux
mon la jolie sont des communes où la
population enseignante est
principalement est principalement jeune
et
féminine ça on va pas c'est comme ça
c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est le système
le système de l'éducation naale et des
points
surtout pour l'aspect féminin de la
profession c'est une généralité c'est
pas propr sur trap mais les enseignants
plus jeunes en revanche c'est
effectivement
lié phénomène exceptionnel sur trap
cette année nous avons 25 enseignantes
qui sont en congé maternité donc nous
leur souhaitons tout le bonheur hein un
petit un petit Sam qui est venu qui est
né la semaine dernière donc voilà donc
bienvenue dans la bienvenue dans la vie
et je salue les parents et euh donc
voilà enfin voilà on a donc ces 25
congés maternité plus s'ajoute les les
arrêts les arrêts les arrêts maladies de
longue durée et les arrêts ponctuels
alors effectivement comme Monsieur le
Directeur Académique a dit il y a
effectivement les les stages et la
formation continue alors effectivement
les C enseignants qu'on a eu sont
effectivement au détriment des des
remplacements de stage et des formations
continue ça veut dire que pour ces
secteurs là spécifiques qui sont en Z il
faudrait des plans spéciaux débloquer
prévoir plus d'enseignants remplaçant
pour justement nous ça fa ça fait ça
fait 4 ans qu'on demande qu' qu'un
calcul
soit soit A une refondation c'est le mot
dans dans l'éducation nationale qui une
refondation du calcul des attributions
de moyens de remplacement alors
effectivement les les les les les
personnes changent les les questions
restent les mêmes on
a nous avions également interpellé
monsieur payon à l'époque sur cette
question là euh voilàisant en attend
alors il semblerait que là effectivement
les services de la les services
départemental de l'Éducation nationale
prennent mais commencent à prendre en
compte cette cette cette possibilité et
Monsieur Macron donc directeur
académique adjoint que nous avons
rencontré ce matin
euh a pris semble-t-il a pris conscience
effectivement de cette nécessité les
services académiques le directeur
académique qui sont en train
d'identifier les circonscriptions qui
ont le plus de difficultés en matière de
remplacement pour préparer la rentrée
prochaine et essayer de répondre au
difficultés qui qui sont rencontrées
mais d'ors et déjà dans votre commune
êtes-vous confronté avec vos enfants à
la difficulté de trouver un remplaçant
pour les pour les professeurs c'est
notre question du jour vos
réponses non pour l'instant non j'ai pas
eu ce problème il y en a oui oui oui il
y en a je moi je travaille aveement dans
une école c'est très bien mais nous on
na pas trop ce problème là mais il y en
a ouais non moi j'en ai pas entendu
parler donc l'école que j'ai franchement
elle est super bien
encour village l'école elle est
fonctionne super bien tourne super bien
mais j'ai pas eu ce genre de problème là
par les profs moi je suis toute récente
dans l'école et malheureusement j'ai
heureusement je n'ai pas encore ru ce
souci là c'est sûr que ça arrive oui
plus qu'on le croit et malheureusement
faut que ça change c'est un problème qui
touche à peu près toutes les communes
mais on l'a vu c'est spécifique aussi
sur trap est-ce que vous avez le soutien
justement des enseignants dans votre
démarche ce matin mobilisation il y une
quinzaine dizaine de personnes qui
étaient présentes vous êtes soutenu par
la communauté éducative la comm
communauté éducative effectivement ben
on également les conséquences hein quand
vous avez je prends l'exemple de la de
l'école Torres qui a dû alors entre
guillemets parquer 80 élèves dans les
autres classes parce qu'effectivement il
y ait pas d'enseignant euh d'abord ça
alors ça ça déstructure directement tout
le travail de l'école he c'est les
classes qui reçoivent ne ne sont pas
dans les bonnes conditions pour
travailler les enfants ne sont pas mis
non plus dans des des
conditions adéquates pour un élève he je
dire quand vous avveit des tes obligé
dans de de de faire asseoir au au sol
les enfants c'est pas normal et c'est
pas non plus c'est pas acceptable et
puis même l'enseignante elle-même ne
peut pas le vivre sereinement il y a un
sujet qui est revenu encore aujourd'hui
dans l'actualité parce que vous évoquez
ces difficultés à attrappe il y a aussi
la réforme des rythmes scolaire qui
concerne tous les enfants mais est-ce
que c'est un un problème supplémentaire
pour pour vous le le sujet qui revient
en ce moment c'est la fatigue des
enfants est-ce que vous l'apercevez je
profite de votre présence car vous vous
occupez de ce dossier aussi alors la la
la fatigue scolaire on l'a beaucoup
ressenti ressenti l'année dernière bon
moi effec à l'origine çaté mis en
placejà si je reviens en 2008 quand on a
eu les réformes de Monsieur darkos la
suppression du du du samedi où
effectivement j'étais favorable à ce
qu'on déplace les horaires et non pas à
ce qu'on les supprime hm hm l'année
dernière nous avons eu la donc le
l'expérience d'avoir une une semaine
continue avec le samedi avec le mercredi
où effectivement là les enfants étaient
euh je dire HS disons-le directement dès
dès le jeudi effectivement bah les le
vendredi les enfants ne captaient plus
rien au jour d'aujourd'hui alors
la au jour d'aujourd'hui on n pas on a
on n pas un système qui est qui est
parfait h euh mais je considère qu'il a
quand même pris en compte toutes les
toutes les les toutes les demandes on a
pris enfin je on a trouvé un consensus
entre donc les les services de la
municipalité les enseignants et
également les les réponses des parents
enfin les souhaits des parents par
rapport au questionnaires pour la
préparation du pedt donc projet éducatif
des territoires où effectivement 69 %
des parents voulaient avoir l'accent
sur sur l'aide au devoir donc moi en
tant que représentant de parents je
n'irai pas à l'encontre de de des
parents de trappe donc le système tel
qu'il fonctionne sur les rythmes c'est
je pense al il il est pas parfait h mais
il fonctionne mais il fonctionne alors
et mais on rentre on rentre alors on
rentre dans le cadre de la loi où
effectivement les les enfants
travaillent moins sur la journée puisque
euh il y a 2 ans il finissit à 16h30 et
après ils avaient encore une heure
d'étude là 16h30 euh ils se terminent
l'étude est faite hmm et en plus pour
une étude une étude euh une étude
gratuite pas encore dirigée parce qu'on
en manque que d'encadrant HM voilà
aprèstiv les activités les activités qui
démarrent à donc à 16h30 euh lors d'une
réunion au mois de décembre on se on
s'est engagé effectivement essayer de
faire un inventaire euh centre par
centre pour voir où est-ce qu'on en est
et des fois rassurer les parents parce
et et également pointer là où ça
fonctionne très bien je vais juste
regarder en plateau une toute petite
minute encore pour évoquer un tout
dernier sujet parce que je sais que vous
n'avez pas spécialement apprécié vous
avez essayé de sensibiliser autour de ça
suite à la vague d'attentat qui a touché
la France il y a eu des minutes de
silence on a beaucoup parlé de de de ces
phénomènes d'élèves qui ne voulait pas
la la respecter mais alors sur trap vous
avez pointé un enseignant qui lui ne
voulait pas la respecter oui tout à fait
dans un
lycée lycée Matis je je je vais le citer
nous avons un enseignant qui
effectivement n'a pas fait n'a pas fait
la minute du silence avec à ses ses
élèves alors moi ça m'a un petit peu
quelle explication vous a donné par
rapport à ça j'ai pas pas eu
l'exlication madame Madame le
Proviseur nous a nous a affirmé nous a
promis que le qu'il y aurait sanction
suite à à cet événement que le directeur
académique était également sur le sujet
et sur ce point-là je leur fa je leur
fais confiance ce qui m'a ce qui m'a
énervé effectivement au niveau
médiatique c'est effectivement c'est
qu'on a partout dans tout dans toutes
sur toutes les chaînes on a on a
stigmatisé ces
jeunes qui qui qui refusaient la de
silence personnellement je ne les je ne
les approuve pas dans dans leur démarche
après on après chacun chacun chacun on
va dire à ses raisons mais alors dans
dans dans cette période d'union
nationale là où effectivement c'est
c'est un enseignant donc une personne
qui est autorité qui a autorité sur la
transmission des valeurs
d'enseignement voilà on est
en là ENF je dire dans les il y a
message qui est pas qui est pas clair
merci Nicolas hardi donc mobilisation
pour l'Union nationale des associations
autonomes des parents d'élèves vous
l'avez entendu tout à l'heure autour de
ces problèmes de remplacement des
enseignants et sur les autres
problématiques on vous a aussi entendu
merci à vous merci le journal se
poursuit avec le préfet des ivelin qui
était hier mardi à la caserne des
pompiers de Versailles il a lancé à
cette occasion la campagne sur les
détecteurs de fumé ces derniers sont
obligatoires dans tous les foyer
français à partir du 8 mars tous les
détails avec Michel midoro et le
dimine
PAP allez viens ma
puce pas temp une loi pour sauver des
vies à partir du 8 mars tous les foyers
français devront être équipés d'un
détecteur de fumée Pierre Morange député
de la 6e circonscription desivel est à
l'origine de ce texte l'homme politique
s'est lancé dans ce combat suite au
décès d'une jeune fille de 16 ans dans
un incendie à chaven en
2002 en fait habité à Saint-Non la
Bretèche mais sa sa fille était avait
passé une soirée avec des amis en effet
à chavenet et elle m'a relassé ce
raconter cette histoire terrible les
larmes aux yeux avec une dignité une
émotion qui prenait la gorge
véritablement et pour le médecin le
maire du un village le père de famille
le parlementaire ilant quelques lueurs
en matière de protection sanitaire et
sociale et ben bien évidemment je lui ai
proposé que nous nous battions ensemble
afin que euh de cette souffrance et bien
nous puissions et bien la mettre au
service de tous cette histoire n'est pas
un cas isolé en moyenne 350 personnes
perdent la vie chaque année dans un
incendie domestique en France dans les
ivelines 1 à 6 décès sont recensés par
enensite à l'inhalation de fumée toxique
dans 70 % des cas les accidents se
produisent la nuit il y a des grandes
idées qui font qu'on estime toujours que
ça va se passer chez les autres et qu'on
aura le temps de réagir au cas où et en
fait malheureusement notre expérience
montre que c'est rarement le cas et que
des drames à la fois matériels mais
surtout humains sont des conséquences de
cette manque de préparation un détecteur
de fumée coûte en moyenne entre 15 et 25
€ un seul avertisseur peut permettre
d'assurer la sécurité d'un appartement
si votre habitation comprend plusieurs
étages il est conseillé d'installer un
détecteur à chaque palier ne peut
installer qu'un seul détecteur de fumée
puisque c'est le minimum imposé par la
loi il faut privilégier le couloir qui
dessert les chambres en général puisquon
pourra réveiller en même temps plusieurs
personnes dans dans le moment de la
journée où elles sont plus fragiles les
plus exposés parce qu'elles dorment dans
la cuisine ce qu'on conseille par contre
c'est un détecteur de chaleur qui lui
sonnera quand la
température de la pièce sera supérieure
au fonctionnement et à l' tente normal
qu'on peut avoir dans ce genre de pièce
objectif annoncé par les soldats du feu
réduire par deux le nombre de morts dans
les incendies en France dans les
prochaines
années un nouveau lieu d'accueil par
enfant a été inauguré ce weekend à
Guille en cours si l'on existe déjà
beaucoup dans le département celui-ci a
une particularité il est destiné aux
familles ayant un enfant en situation de
handicap jusqu'à 5 ans handicap moteur
mental sensoriel financé notamment par
le Lyon club des trois villages ce
nouvel espace veut sortir les personnes
de l'isolement comme va nous l'expliquer
yolen
Torz pas facile tu as
vu 1 de 3 soleil lieu d'accueil enfant
par an a été inauguré ce weekend à guon
courour ouvert depuis la mi novembre à
l'initiative de l'association du fun
pour tous les locaux sont destinés en
priorité aux familles avec un enfant en
situation de handicap et âgé de 0 à 5
ans les familles qui apprennent que leur
enfant est handicapé entre 0 et 5 ans
doivent faire face à de nombreuses
prises en charge médical et paramédical
et ça crée de l'isolement
progressivement donc nous on veut aider
ces familles pour sortir de l'isolement
et leur permettre justement d'avoir un
lieu ressources pour pouvoir se poser
euh partager des moments ludiques et
sympathiques avec son enfant et pouvoir
échanger aussi avec d'autres parents
accueillis par des professionnels de la
petite enfance et du secteur
médico-social les parents bénéficient
d'un soutien anonyme et gratuit les
enfants quant à eux profitent d'un
espace motricité avec quelques toboggans
d'un espace créativité avec peinture et
coloriage ou encore d'un espace détente
bibliothèque de temps en temps aussi des
activités cuisine et pâtisserie sont
organisées avec les parrains de
l'association deux grands chef au grand
cœur comme aujourd'hui par exemple on a
préparé un buffet on a pu faire de la
pâte à cookies avec eux
donc de les voir travailler la patte
d'avoir du c'est des choses qui m'ont
qui me plais beaucoup en fait moi je
suis jeune papa et c'est vrai que quand
je regarde ma fille je me dis mais s'il
y avait eu quoi que ce soit heureusement
heureusement qu'il y a des il y a des
gens comme ça qui vous viennent en aide
parce que ça doit être vous devez vous
retrouver dans une
détresse telle que heureusement qu'il y
a des institutions comme ça qui disent
où on est là on on va pas régler tous
vos problèmes en tout cas on va vous
venir en aide ce nouvel espace peut
accueillir jusqu'à 18 personnes en même
temps il est ouvert deux matinées par
semaine le lundi et le jeudi de 9h à
11h30 hors vacance
scolair c'est la fin du journal on se
retrouve demain sur les mêmes horaires
pour un nouveau point sur l'actualité
locale très bonne soirée sur notre
[Musique]
antenne